Good morning, Hank; it's Monday. I'm at Bill
and Eileen's house. Bill and Eileen were my
first bosses, or at least some of my first
bosses at Booklist magazine. Eileen Cooper
is the reason, of course, that I am an author.
She is an author herself of books like Sam
I Am and The Golden Rule. This is the Korean
edition, because Eileen doesn't have an English
edition, but anyway this book is dedicated
to me. I would show you but the dedication
is in – is in – is in Korean.
So Hank your video on Friday was amazing and
I still can't get over the fact that nerdfighters
found Gussie Manlove even though she wasn't
named Gussie Manlove when she died--she was
named Audrey Brown, and she wasn't named Gussie
Manlove when she was born--she was named Gussie
Horsey, which is the worst name ever!
Or at least I thought it was the worst name
ever until I started doing research on the
topic.
So today, Hank, I present to you my list of
six unfortunate names from history.
Number six: Dick Trickle. Hank, when it comes
to Dicks you have a lot of unfortunate name
choices like Dick Sweat, the former congressman,
or Dick Army.
But to my mind the best at being worst is
Dick Trickle, who was a NASCAR driver. Aside
from being famous for being named Dick Trickle,
Dick Trickle was also famous because he was
the only NASCAR driver in history who had
a hole screwed into his helmet so that he
could smoke in the middle of races. He had
his pit crew install a cigarette lighter in
his stock car, and one time after a race with
very few caution flags he said "That race
went by so fast I only had time for two cigarettes!"
Number five: Ima Hogg. The daughter of Texas
governor "Big Jim Hogg." Ima Hogg was known
as 'The First Lady of Texas', probably because
no one wants to be known as Ima Hogg. She
was a great patron of the arts, she collected
works by Picasso and Matisse, and she was
a philanthropist, and she also has an honorary
degree meaning that technically her name is
Dr. Ima Hogg.
Number four: Harry Baals. Hank, Harry Baals
has been much in the news lately because there
is a move by the city of Fort Wayne to name
a building after their beloved former mayor,
Harry Baals. His name really was Harry Baals
and he is a very beloved former mayor. Like,
I hear all the time on talk radio in Indiana
people saying "You know those East Coast people,
they can tell us 'You can't name a building
the Harry Baals Government Center!' Well,
what this town needs is more Harry Baals."
Number three: Shanda Lear, the daughter of
the guy who founded the Learjet corporation.
Shanda Lear, uh, grew up to become a lead
singer in swing bands.
Number two: Hymen Lipman, who was the first
person to ever attach an eraser to a pencil.
And number one: Chris P Bacon, a composer
living in Los Angeles who writes music for
movies. Like, he contributed music to such
music as Gnomeo and Juliet, Michael Clayton,
I Am Legend... and, Hank, he wrote the entire
original score for the American classic Space
Chimps. Also just to reiterate, his name is
Chris P Bacon.
So Hank it just goes to show you that merely
having a horrible name like Chris P Bacon
or Gussie Manlove doesn't mean that you can't
go on to great things like writing the score
for the movie Space Chimps.
Funny-named individuals, don't lose hope.
Hank, I'll see you on Wednesday.